here's a question for you if a guy steps
out and
cheats um would you end the relationship
or would you just look the other way if
he was taking care of the family the
kids the house your car was you know
looked after everything's in place
nothing changes would you want to untie
the knot or would you just look the
other way and say I can only do it so
much I'm only interested so much let him
do what he wants just don't embarrass me
no I I I would be done because for me
the trust is like the trust would be
broken so like unless they we could work
on like work on that issue I if it was
overly stated and you knew that he was
doing it then there's no trust to be
broken because you understand that he's
doing it oh I wouldn't be with someone
that I knew was doing it got it
yeah what about Angie and Mandy um I
didn't if I didn't
know um then or like if how do I explain
it like if I don't know why would like I
already knew he was cheating and then
like I
already I don't know I don't feel like
I'd agreed to that to having like an
open relationship or like but if I found
out and I already had like a family and
I had everything set if it was just one
time like probably but if it was like
over and over and over and over again
yeah I'd probably leave yeah
Andre it depends I guess um
how common is it in your culture from
your
country not at all I
mean if the girl is
like
um you can tell like when a guy cheat
the the wife is always that type like I
don't know it's like a
certain um so what would it depend on
because it sounds like it's
conditional yeah um yeah it is
conditional everything think this is
conditional I don't
think um anyway um I will talk about it
with him in terms of like okay if let's
say are you g to I'm going to ask him
are you going to keep doing it if he
said yes okay cool so where is the happy
medium like I don't know we'll just
figure out something out so no I'm not
gonna so it's not the end of the
relationship see because I personally
think and I'll die on this hill I think
women are incredibly selfish if a guy is
provided for family chosen a wife taken
care of everything the bills are looked
after she doesn't have to worry the
children are looked after he does the
family events I think women are
incredibly selfish and stupid for ending
a marriage and leaving a guy thinking
that the grass is greener somewhere else
and destroying that family and
separating the children from the uh
parents especially if they're
small but it's not so much it sometimes
it's not selfishness but it's also
valuing yourself right I value myself to
be treated better cuz my dad's also like
you know told me that I deserve to be
treated with respect right and if you're
going to no but he's still treating you
he's still treating you with respect
there's no woman that's going to come
knocking on your door saying Dana I have
your husband's baby there's no him
taking her on vacations and treating her
like a wife or anything like that
there's no her him taking her to the
family restaurant where you guys go with
the kids and one of your friends take a
picture out of the bank account none of
that there's there's still the respect
component that exists but well it's it's
existing to to benefit him right like
it's it's not I'm not getting just
exercise he's not falling in love with
these women no because he wouldn't feel
the same way if I did it well it's
different because when women do it then
there's an emotional attachment when
they do it but there's some women like
you know what I mean that can have
sexual encounters just on a whim and
just have them without that sexual
component that's actually not true
because I I knew the lawyer that set up
Ashley Madison I don't know if you're
familiar with the brand yeah so I so I
knew the lawyer that worked in the legal
team for Ashley Madison and I learned
that a lot of the stuff that they do
like a lot lot of the marketing and a
lot of the holding out that they do to
the public is pretty much all lies right
like there's no women on there that are
just doing it like and just going back
to the husbands and it's just there's no
emotional attachment most of the [__]
that you see on there is is fake and
it's used to siphon money off of simps
and and dudes that think that they're
going to get some side action so I'm not
saying like these women don't they I it
would for sure affect their relationship
more than it would like a m right he
said a guy could go do it come home and
be with his family and provide and
continue like nothing happen where women
will change their behavior right because
it it is the emotional aspect that way
but yeah they generally stop sleeping
with their husband they generally are
more distant they'll spend more time
with their friends they'll take weekends
away and disappear all of that right
they yeah they kind of just become
everything that he wouldn't want yeah
but yeah I don't know I just think it's
you know what the stats are like for
children from uh single mother
households because 43% of households now
are raising children as a single parent
household you know they are I'm I could
speak as like a
my I have both my parents but like I
mostly just like and growing up I was
like taking um my dad's side more and I
was just so speaking from like a sure
child from single father I feel
like I mean I feel like it was better um
seeing that like my parents were happier
separated and you know my mom wasn't
like super super around but when she was
she was she was good and you know my dad
help so his ass and that was his choice
and you know so I think that it's I
think it's good I think it just depends
on like the person entirely you were
raised predominantly by your father
though not your mother right yeah mostly
by because that's the huge difference
right the vast majority of of single
parent households or single mother
household I think it's something like I
mean north of 80% I think it's like one
in five single single parent households
are are single fathers and a lot of that
has to do with the Western court system
and the way family law is set up um but
yeah it's it's it's interesting that you
say that
um yeah just want to throw that out
there I covered some of the details in
my book but just off top of my head the
vast majority of uh Teenage gang
activity pregnancies abortions uh shitty
grades runaways uh the vast majority of
the incarcerated today come from single
mother households um women do an
incredibly poor job of raising uh boys
and girls to be men and women um which
is why I I think anyway if the guy's
taken care of the household and he loves
a family and he's just stepped out and
it's nothing serious it's nothing like
an emotional attachment these women are
incredibly selfish and they're
destroying families by doing stuff like
this I'm not saying it's right or it's
wrong what I'm saying is I think it's a
real bad idea and it hurts the children
and it hurts family and it hurts the
fabric of society over something that's
really just exercised for 20 minutes I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out